[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bravo c'est vrai si le bonhomme cetelem
était vachement mais s'ils sont
jean-michel aroui géant messieurs le
maire et gilles verdez et ce qu'ils
peuvent venir les chiens
[Applaudissements]
saleh 4 hier de jean luc lemoine et il
ya une patte de jean michel mr et gilles
verdez donc ils sont là ce soir
exactement avec le suisse la question
bonjour je m'appelle marque
je voulais vous dire que je ne regarde
votre émission que pour maxime guény car
lui au moins il me rappelle la télé
d'autrefois
comment fait-il pour paraître si jeune à
65 ans je comprends cette question
chamakh mais le secret maxime est simple
il est passé 60 50 car il en a 30
je sais il se passe des choses derrière
alors je sais c'est choquant qu'il ait
30 ans mais c'est pourtant la vérité
d'ailleurs si vous voulez comprendre la
relation de jean michel mr et maxime
gainey je vous invite à regarder le film
hibernatus avec des à côtés louis de
funès un ancien irascible et l'autre un
vieux jeunes qui sursaute à la moindre
occasion
là c'était pendant un blind test enfin
un blindtest version tpm pays où on doit
répondre avec ses pieds bayer eu des
petits recadrage pour l'été pour faire
un peu plus émission médias quand le
pied d'un jour michel avec son gros
oignon a parlé d'un seul coup dans votre
champ de vision
ça peut surprendre la frayeur de la
semaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est là on se dit qu'il est
différent de nous on se fout de tout du
décor lui sa vraie inquiétude c'est
vinci jean michel a rayé la table ou par
la suite encore mieux vous avez reconnu
la musique là oui c'est qui ça s'est
battue elle détient aujourd'hui au ski
c'est d'avoir compilé peu mieux que vous
le sachiez
c'est une de mes chansons préférées
viance romantique
ouais cyril demande de se donner la main
à tout le monde le problème c'est que
maxime est toujours assis à côté de jean
michel
[Musique]
je pensais
il atteint alors celle-là talent donc
maxime c'est le chroniqueur modèlerait
enfin ça l'était jusqu'à la semaine
dernière
car oui pour la première fois il a
montré des signes de faiblesse jusqu'à
présent il était infaillible quand il
est venu donner la parole est là devant
nos yeux ébahis ont recommandé un way
pour parler comme lui le ferai que ce
langage moderne
patatras les obsédés en cuisine on va
maintenant passer à la meilleure
boulangerie transmarck pas terrible en
bateau prenant j'ai pas l'aide de l'iran
[Rires]
les enfants record en audience hier à la
palestine un record combien entière
voilà 510 milles avant clair qu'avant
clients tiers oui d'accord j'ai 24
heures de retard
[Applaudissements]
que s'est il passé comment maxime at il
pu passer au travers de la réponse un
merci ça va vous choquer kelly je vais
te briser le coeur
si maxime avait l'air à côté de ces bons
c'est juste parce que la veille au soir
il était sorti avec à gâteau proulx et
virginie notre styliste
j'aime bien c'est croustillant
alors vous allez me dire c'est pas
grand-chose de sortie au ski mais faut
le remettre dans le contexte faut
comparer ce qui est comparable
maxime qui sort c'est comme un enfant de
12 ans qui boit un verre de punch à
universal de son papy n'est pas habitué
résultat ça donne ces images qu'on
n'aurait jamais voulu voir c'est non
[Musique]
ça marche pas terrible bataille n'est
pas l'aide de l'iran sont heureusement
que cyril est là pour tenir la baraque
ces terroristes avec des rigolos qui
font les fous fous dans les karaokés que
l'émission va maintenir son niveau
cyril l'a dit cette année l'émission
sera plus sérieuse puis ce soir là ont
diffusé le film ghost
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
monument classé
non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
cas félicitations fait très bien le
tigre à dents de sabre avec des images
on peut les vendre pastilla national
geographic l'aider comme s'inscrit l'aï
écrite tellement et tout le temps que
parfois il se perd si je vous dis bonne
taux moyen sûr de ce qui s'est passé
chez le guerneve gilles verdez on
regarde un petit rappel on rappelle le
bot nourris si les gobelets comme ça
fait trembler sur la table de la mer
voilà bah vous savez quoi
vous m'avez tellement sous les noms
écoutez moi bien vous allez lui préparer
trois gobelets avec une table aller
faire du bon donc s'il y avait eu
l'excellente idée d'organiser un
benneteau et gilles verdez dans la rue
c'était diffusé qu'en dans l'émission ça
ça ouais mais parce qu'en fait il est à
wind on l'a eue à qui on avait un petit
extrait sinon parce que c'est ça le
problème avec cyril il annoncé après
l'oubli
sinon on a eu un peu dans la rue sociaux
certains passent et d'oublier mais sauf
que pendant que vous parliez médias il y
avait l'ancien rédacteur en chef du
parisien qui s'excitent est dehors avec
trois gobelets pour vous comprenez bien
vous avez vu les images et les ses
leçons de ce qui se passait au même
moment en plateau d'un grand moment de
solitude
n'a pas d'extrait ah oui wayport à
mechelle bien moi c'est qu'il a marre
j'aime bien bien bien c'est la société
faut citer d'autres marques de luxe
[Applaudissements]
parce que les copains ça votre
feuilleton préféré bien sûr qu'est ce
que c'est que ce forture d'agathe et
kelly une fille et une fille
ouais série palpitante au scénario
bourré de rebondissements dans l'épisode
précédent agathe et qu'il y ait bien les
couleurs de leurs vêtements donc faisait
des scènes fille bague à trouver que le
ses fils il faisait une grosse tête
d'où un problème leur amitié allait-elle
en pâtir allez y renoncer la réponse
tout de suite
j'adore
[Musique]
c'est un voleur parodie
non mais je déteste les gens voient pas
mais toutes les autres
[Musique]
on leur apprend que le tien une erreur
oui
mais ouais c'est quoi ton portable à
temps
j'aime parfait
je ne vois pas
[Musique]
pour saint palais
maintenant ça lui fait des yeux trop
petit on a quatre s'accepte comme lé
sinon annuler cette fille maintenant
pareil de meriem la nouvelle
chroniqueuse a paru la semaine dernière
alors je dois parler maintenant parce
qu'en ce moment il ya un tel passage
dans cette émission que je sais pas
qu'on va la revoir
1 d'ailleurs à partir de la semaine
prochaine chaque chroniqueur aura un
badge avec son prénom dessus donc que
cyril et les téléspectateurs puissent y
retrouvez donc meriem est venu aider les
génériques de début on a vu qu'elle
allait bien
[Applaudissements]
une fille qui fait le robot tu dis ah
ouais la bonne chroniqueuse alors si en
plus elle s'y connaît un peu en actu
médias mal faisait une vanne sur family
battle
c'est comme si on faisait revenir la
famille en or sur ces 8
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
en sept ans on a vu passer pas mal de
monde au thon à table mais on n'avait
pas encore eu de chroniqueuse pour les
sourds et malentendants qui traduit en
six qui se passe dans l'émission
lakhdaria mc rectifié bat ferrer seul ne
vous écoute
[Applaudissements]
ça en langage des signes
ça veut dire que tu as bien fait à
casser la gueule bien sûr vous allez
dire pourquoi qu'est-ce qui a fait la
différence pourquoi cyril at-elle fait
at il fait appel à elle et bien
simplement parce que cyril c'est un
bosseur un s'arrête pas aux évidences en
consultant le passé militaire de meriem
il s'est dit qu'elle avait toutes les
qualités pour nous rejoindre
papa
c gepa
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le profil qu'on n'avait pas avec un
regard super expressif
alors c'est mon moment préféré c'est
quand il tape va faire une vanne
non mais rien ne va pas du tout apprécié
d'être coupé devant essai clinique est
ce qu'il veut y avait le caresser chez
doucement bonjour donc aussi attiser des
gentils laisse nous tranquille enfin du
lit à regarder mais dans toutes les
émissions tout et me donner c'est sûr et
il a fini enfin moi enfin je parle pas
en tant que père c'est vraiment j'adore
les cafards
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je parle en tant que spectacle ça engage
les six meilleurs d'accueil en tout cas
ça fait une très belle transition pour
le top j'ai danse population des petits
moments étranges et inclassable de tpm p
j'adore voilà c'est des images tu les
vois que tu fais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cassel et monica sagna
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
nous
cette émission
[Musique]
les très maline donc elle dit toujours
ce qu'elle ce qu'il va faire un peu le
buzz mais c'est pas vrai réponse
maintenant je me sens
[Musique]
et ça fait même plaisir quand vous êtes
dans l'émission merci nous savons à coup
de gueule à gâteau coup oui
[Musique]
sur des recommandations public que
laboratoire de la formule absolument
c'est pour que ces procès cette bourse
fait pour des gens me
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]